suburbia is a really easy target for
architects and urban planners today and
I I suppose two different people it
means different things and there's
always new terms or new words being
invented for it and there's theorists
who come out in support of it in certain
ways and I think people that live in the
suburbs and I know particular people
that I've done gardens for in the
suburbs feel attacked at times because
it's it's such an easy target and it's
such an easy place to hate for for
certain kind of people and there's a lot
of kind of new urban planning ideas that
seek to kind of attack the suburbs the
way we have them today and take us back
to you know maybe a few hundred years
ago when we didn't have a car so there's
a lot of there's a lot of discourse
around the suburbs today and I think
it's really easy space to hate and to UM
to just completely toss out and start
over again my I mean I have a pretty
intense connection to it I think because
I grew up in the suburbs I grew up going
to malls and mowing front lawns and you
know that's the world I grew up in so I
think part of the edible estates project
has grown out of that intimate awareness
of that landscape and that sort of what
it means to live in the suburbs I I
don't know I I guess I'm less interested
in in creating some new utopia from
scratch than I am in really reckoning
with the world that we live in today and
how each of us can take ownership of
what we've created for ourselves and to
live in it in a more humane and
thoughtful way mm-hmm so I tend not to
thing in in in big grand gestures of
remaking new cities what is our new city
look like because we we don't have the
opportunity
to make new cities anymore and we don't
make them overnight and the ones that we
do tend to be miserable disasters
because they're created by one or two or
a handful of people for the masses
imposing our will upon you know people
that will never meet so I tend to be
much more interested in movements in
ways of taking back control of what
we've made for ourselves in ways that
each individual has complete control of
or each individual is given Liberty to
make within within our cities within our
suburbs and they're small piece of land
what what they would like for themselves
you